Hello 大家好
欢迎回到Lindsay的频道
前两天我就做了一个性格测试
叫做NBTI性格测试
我这个人吧
平时之前是不怎么太相信这种测试的
我觉得一般那种测试结果说出来
是个人可能都有7% 80%能对上
所以我不太相信那个
但这个做出来的
我真的觉得分析的简直就是鞭辟入理
条条在理啊
所以呢我就后来又对他的逻辑背景
这方面进行了一个研究
然后我就越看越觉得
说的实在是太有道理了
所以我今天就特别迫不及待的
想把MBTI性格测试
跟大家来分享一下
顺便说一句
其实现在全球500强的企业
有80%都在用这个框架
来给他的员工进行性格测试
然后好觉得
这个人适合做这个
所以今天整个视频
也会比较
就是会有一些互动
就是大家可以跟着我一起
来测一测
看看自己到底是什么样的性格
同时你也可以了解一下
你的优点缺点
你跟什么人相处会更合适
跟什么人不太适合相处
然后能更了解自己
更了解身边的人
也能有个更好的人际关系
简单来讲
这个MBTI就叫MireBrick
Type Indicator
就是以这个测试的创始人命名的
它简单来说呢
是通过四个维度
把人分成
每个维度里都有两个类
所以就是二的四次
反正把人分成16种类型
所以今天呢
咱们做完之后
你就会是这16个里边结果中的一个
那我们就开始吧
那我们先来说这第一个维度啊
第一个维度简单来说呢
就是你是外向还是内向啊
就是它是说
你的能量一般是从什么地方来获取的
我们先来看几道题
第一题
现在大家想象
如果说你现在经历了一个
特别劳累的一周
要么你上班特别辛苦
要么你刚期末考试完
或者就很累的时候
你是会选择去蹦迪
或者去party
或者去好好嗨一下
还是我自己回家
我打游戏或者刷剧
就在这懒着
我们这样吧
做这个题的时候
一般我会给两个答案
然后一个大家就记一分
一个就记负一分
当然你在做的这中间
如果你觉得不是那么的靠这个一
那么绝对
你就可以给自己
比如说0.5 0.7
你就自己看着办吧
到时候咱们把这个分加总
然后就通过这个了
来看看你到底是属于哪个类型
所以刚才那两个选项
如果你是倾向于去嗨去蹦d的
你就给自己计一分
如果你是喜欢自己
比如说打游戏
你就计负一分
好 这是第一题
好 现在我们来看第二题
第二题就假设在一个
很大的party上
都可能有很多陌生人
而这时候你就被cue到了
你变成了一个
众目睽睽之下的焦点
这个时候你会不会感到
有一些尴尬或者不适
有些人呢可能就
啊没事
我觉得很好
我就是喜欢成为
众目归归之下的焦点
我觉得非常的荣耀啊
这种同学呢就计一分
如果你是觉得
啊我非常不是
我不喜欢这样子
我不喜欢大家都盯着我看
你就计负一分啊
好
好那我们现在来看第三道题
大家想一想自己
平时交朋友的一个态度
你是更偏向于说
OK大家这个四海之内
接兄弟啊
交朋友嘛
对吧
先交朋友再说
如果之后合不来
大不了再给掰了
还是呢你会觉得
交朋友也需要谨慎
防人之心不可恶
一开始呢
我还是要跟对方
保持一些距离
等慢慢熟了
一点一点再亲近
你看看你是哪一个类型
那我在屏幕上
还会再放几道题啊
感兴趣小伙伴
可以再做一下
基本上你做的越多
测的准的概率
就会越大一些
好 那我们现在做完了
我来看一下
大家可以把刚才那些分
给加总
那如果你加完之后呢
你的分是一个正的
那你就更偏外向型
就是extrovert
就是E
那如果说你加起来是负的
你就更偏introvert
就是内向型
是I
第一个呢
其实也比较好理解
虽然它不像大家平时
想象当中的说
外向就是爱说话
内向就是不爱说话
没有这么简单
外向型的人呢
他们一般是会通过
外界的刺激来汇取能量
所以他们一般会跟人更亲近
比较喜欢表达和交流自己的观点
那你看啊
这种四海之内接兄弟
肯定是个外向的人说的话
对吧
他们一般解决问题的时候呢
也会倾向于把自己的
这些观点都表达出来
爱说的人一般都会成为人的焦点
所以一般外向的人
他们也不太介意成为人的焦点
甚至啊他们挺喜欢
感觉吸引到关注的
还有一个挺有意思的事呢
就是外向的人
他们不是容易
接受到外界的刺激
得到能量吗
所以一般外向人
喝咖啡也容易
更容易精神
还挺有意思的
那反过来说内向的人
内向人就是说
他获取能量的方式
更多的是通过
自己跟自己相处
就在一些比较
安静的环境当中
自己慢慢就能恢复过来
所以其实内向的人
不是我们平时想象的
就特别的害羞
完全不能出去
跟人打交道
出去social的
其实有一些内向的人
他们的这个社交的能力
也很强
但只不过
他们出去跟人
唠唠唠唠唠
挺长时间
他们就还得
自己回家缓一会
才能缓过来
就是老这么说
会让他们觉得很累
所以内向的人
一般相对来讲
就喜欢安静一点的地方
他们的娱乐方式
可能比如说
自己看看书
打游戏
刷剧
或者自己出去独处
就这种相处的方式
所以他们平时
也不是特别喜欢
表露自己的喜怒哀乐
包括想问题
想事
都是一般
是他们喜欢想好了
再说
当他们想好的时候
他们说你有的时候会觉得他们是一个外向的人
这就是外向和内向
一个字母大家记好了
看你到底是意还是哀
在往下说之前呢
补充几个点
一个呢就是这个只是说你性格的一个特点心理学家专有名词叫preference就是你性格你更偏好于哪一种就好像比如说我让你把胳膊盘起来你是会这样的事还是会这样的事
你看我很明显就是这样的事
就是你的一个很自然的一个倾向
就跟外向和内向是一样
不光是这个
咱们之后做的那几个不同的分类
都一样
它没有任何的好坏和优劣之分
还有第二个呢
就是大家在做的时候
就是要对自己特别诚实
就是你是什么样就选什么样
这个咱也不给别人看
尽量不要选
你想成为的那个人
了解了这几点之后呢
我们来看第二个这个维度
第二维度呢
是看你是怎么样
去获取信息的
它也分两种类型
第一种呢
叫做sensing
sensing就是用感官
五官去感知啊
我们把它叫做具体型
第二个呢
叫做intuition
就是说你是通过直觉
去获取信息的
你想象一下
你现在跟你的朋友
或者男女朋友吵架了
你在吵架的时候
你一般呢
是会更会揪那些
特别具体的细节啊
比如说
你为什么今年12点38分
还没起床
你为什么马桶三次不盖杆
你为什么这儿人一只把子
那儿人一只裤子
还是呢
你会更去吵一些抽象的情感
比如说
你为什么脾气这么不好
你为什么把家里弄这么乱
你为什么总是这么懒
OK 大家想一想啊
回顾一下自己吵架的
这些光辉时刻
OK 我们先来看第二题啊
你想一想
你自己平时会不会去
想一些那种
挺有意思
但是有可能
不是特别实际的东西
三体啊 宇宙啊
黑洞 人类起源啊
这种比较抽象的概念
如果你说
这跟我有什么关系
压根不会想这种事
你给自己积一分
如果你说
这个很有意思
我很喜欢看那种
神秘的科幻的东西
你就给自己积负一分
OK
那我们看第三个问题
当别人比如说
给你一篇文章
让你去审
你一般呢
试读读读读读
诶这个错别字
这个字不对
诶这句话语法不对
还是呢
你会先大概看一下
整体的框架说
OK大框还差不多
诶然后我再去具体看
好
那我在屏幕上呢
还会再多放几道题
自己切磋一下
好 我们介绍答案
如果说你得到的是一个正数
在这个维度里面
你就是具体型的
就是S型的
如果说你得到的是一个负数
在这个维度
你就是直觉型的
就是N
为什么是N呢
因为是intuition
那个I在上一个不是被用了吗
所以这个就用N来代替
OK 那这个维度是什么意思呢
如果说你是一个比较具体型的
可以说你是通过五官去感知
所以你会更喜欢一些
比较具体的实际的东西
就比如说
你喜欢看一些数据
看一些数字
看得见摸得着的
不喜欢那种
特别抽象的东西
比如别人给你讲个什么什么东西
就说你别给我扯些有的没的
别扯那些虚的
来举个例子
说点实在的
这样你基本上就是具体型的
具体型的
他们一般更仔细一点
感知这种信息都是根据什么什么
就是根据什么什么数据
根据我看到的一些事实
根据我过去的经历
怎么怎么样
那直觉的N型
他们平时就更抽象一点
就是那种
我觉得吧
我感觉
反正就是我觉得
我要我觉得
就是这种N型的
多一点
直觉型的呢
他们喜欢一些
很大的想法
一般来讲
更有创造力一些
就是会喜欢这种
各种各样
不同的可能性
opportunities
然后big picture
这种感觉的人
所以他们一般
就更喜欢探索一些
比较抽象的
很大的东西
但很可能呢
有的时候会有一些
不切实际
那就比如说
当不同的人
看到下面这幅图的时候
一般那种具体型的人
他就会说
OK 我看到了一个小伞
我又看到了一个箭头
我看到这个树
五颜六色的
各种各样的树干
那相对来讲
直觉性的人就是
我看到了一个森林
里边好像有各种
不同颜色的树木
但据我观察
大多数情况下
女生偏S的会比较多一些
这也是为什么
就是岁数大了
一般家里
都是那个妈妈在家
嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
唠叨那些小事
那个爸爸就跟没听见一样
那也不在乎
那在人群当中呢
其实其他几个维度的人
基本上是五五开的
只有这个S和N
S型的会占大多数
差不多70%
那N呢差不多有30%
这样
补一下口红
OK我们现在做完两组了
那你就有两个字母
要么是ES
要么是IS
要么是EN
要么是IN
好我们现在来做第三个维度
第三个维度呢
就是说当你做决定的时候
你更多的是通过你的thinking
就是思考
还是说通过你的feeling
就是情感
这个呢就是维基百科的翻译
我感觉它不是特别的直观啊
所以我用我的翻译
小林翻译法
就是你是感性型还是理性型
OK我们还接着
第一题就是当一个你的朋友
他跟他男朋友吵架了
或者他遇到一些个人的
就很伤心很难过的时候
你是会选择先听听他
到底怎么回事
然后想办法一前帮他解决问题
这种就记一分
还是你会选择
我先体恤一下他的情感
你说这个事真是太不幸了
我也替你感到悲伤
就怎么办呢
这样的你就记负一分
好 第二题
现在有这么一个情况
你的一个朋友说了一个
什么什么什么理论
你觉得他说的不是很对
但是如果你反驳它
有可能就会产生一些冲突
这时候你会选择怎么做
我不是很介意跟它产生冲突
因为大家讨论问题
你可以给自己积一分
但如果说你觉得
这也不是什么大事
我就不争了吧
免得闹两个人之间
这个矛盾合并呢
对吧
这样你就给自己积负一分
还有几道题呢我还打在这个屏幕上大家感兴趣也可以再做一下做完之后呢把自己那个分加起来然后大家算算自己的分啊如果你是正的呢那就说明你是一个T就是thinking
就是理性
行着
如果呢你是
加起来是一个副分呢
就说明你是F feeling
就是感性性的
理性很好理解对吧
就是你做决定的时候
比较讲逻辑
一二三四五
一般也会比较客观
同时呢
在做决定的时候
也会考虑啊
成本收益
然后看这事做的到底
值不值
然后再去想
要不要干这些事
所以一般理性的人呢
有些人可能会觉得
他们比较冷酷无情
就比较严格
那相对来讲呢
感性啊
和刚才你怎么获取知识
那个我感觉是不一样的
这个主要是说
当你在面对一些
比如说利益的冲突的时候
你是更会理性的做决定
还是更偏向于情感
但是情感不是说
你就意气用事啊
就想什么干什么
不是这个意思
更多的是说
你会从情感的角度考虑
更注重人和人之间的这个和谐
你不太喜欢有冲突
更体恤别人
更关怀别人
所以呢
一般如果说
你问一个理性的人
什么是公正
什么是公平
他们会觉得
公平应该是绝对的公平
一视同仁就叫公平
那如果说感性的人呢
有的时候他们就会觉得
公平是一个
比较相对的概念
它是针对不同的人
应该给予他们
不同的东西
这样呢
才是最大的公平
所以就是
看你平时做决定
是更理性呢
还是更感性
OK
第三个字母是T还是F
我们现在有了
那现在我们来看
最后一组
最后一组是什么意思呢
就是看你平时的
生活方式是什么样子
这里边也分两类
一类呢叫judging
就是判断
另一类呢叫perceiving
perceiving就是感知
这是wikipedia给的翻译啊
当然我还是不赞同
我觉得可以把它翻译成
计划型还是灵活型
这样就好理解很多了
对吧
就是你平时生活
是大概什么样的
废话少说
我们还是先看题
好 第一题
第一题大家可以想一想
自己在平时
比如说做一件事
或者做一个项目的时候
你会更倾向于
我尽可能的在最开始
就是希望更多的事情
都在自己的控制当中
给自己记一分
那另一种呢
就是说这个事好像
也确实有好几步
然后每一步呢
也都不是特别明朗
那我还不如走一步
看一步
走一步多一些信息
我就更容易做决定
这种呢
你就给自己付一份
好
那第二题
这个就比较简单了
你平时呢
是喜欢特别准时
你跟朋友约吃饭
一点就是一点
绝对不1.05到
然后平时都
什么东西都挺规整的
也不辣东西
给自己积一份啊
好饱饱
另一类呢
就是啊
我没什么吃个饭嘛
晚点怎么了
晚五分钟不要紧
那我就1.05到
1.07到
也没什么的
钱包丢了
钥匙丢了
丢了再补嘛
对吧
评来讲讲水来涂眼
看我活得也挺自在
这种同学给自己接付一份
OK
那还有几道题
我也打在了屏幕上
感兴趣小伙伴
可以再做一下
好
那我们做完了
先把这个总分也算出来
如果说你刚才得到的是一个正分
这种就是比较有计划性的
就是这种J型的
那如果说你刚才得到是个负数
你基本上可以把自己定义成一个P型的
比较灵活型的
那J型有计划
对吧
很好理解
就是他平时生活非常非常的
有规律有计划
喜欢什么事都给自己安排好了
就比如说你第二天要出去吃饭
前一天晚上
就把菜单都看好了
想好自己要吃什么
当然也不排除这是个吃货
还有就是这种人特别喜欢
列那个list
to do list
就是列表
每天今天要做一二三四五六七
做一件划一件就感觉很爽
有的时候甚至啊
你都做完了一件事
就为了划的那个爽
你还要把那个再写上去
然后就给它划掉
这种人呢
就非常非常典型的J型的人
那另一派呢
就是比较灵活
比较洒脱
来一场说走就走的旅行
计划型呢
他们也不喜欢别人
打乱他的计划
就是如果说
他今天这个安排都安排好了
突然有一个人说
那我们出去吃个饭吧
他就说我不吃
要不他即使吃了
他也会很焦躁
因为打乱了他的计划
但是呢
这种灵活型的人就不一样
他说来吃个饭
饭好吃
那我先去吃个饭吧
就是比较走一步看一步
每天活得也很潇洒洒脱
但他有的时候呢
就可能没法按时完成作业
会有这些问题
就是这两个
不一样的一个生活状态吧
当然也没有说谁优谁烈啊
OK好
大功告成
那我们现在每个人
都有了四个字母啊
或许你是INFP
或许你是ENTJ
或许你是ISTJ
你大家也可以留言
把结果告诉我
因为每个人的结果不一样
所以我今天可能
也不太有时间
把每一个都分析的特别具体
所以呢
我在下面信息栏里
把这个每个类型的一些特点啊
优缺点啊
一些资料
我打包放在下面了
这个呢
就是这16种性格的人
在人口当中的一个比例
有多有少
当然还是跟刚才说
一样它没有任何好坏之分
就这里边比较有意思的几种
我还稍微做了一点小小的研究
其中有这么几个
一个是呢
就是当你是如果是
IN这两个搭对的时候
因为I就本身比较内向
就跟自己获取能量
N呢又是比较靠直觉
就是自己跟自己在这想
所以一般I和N碰在一起
这种人就特别特别的
这个有一个自我的小世界
也很喜欢研究
所以有的也很聪明
很有意思的一点呢
就是现在最大的几个互联网公司
Flag他们的创始人
Facebook的Mark Zuckerberg
然后LinkedIn的Reed Hoffman
Amazon的Jeff Bezos
Google的Larry Page
这四个人都是爱恩系
然后爱恩系的还有谁呢
像爱因斯坦 过金
还有就是Big Ben里头的Sheldon
这些都是爱恩系典型的代表人
就他们就是那种
自己跟自己整天
好像比较有成就的物理学家
很多都是爱恩系的
这是个挺有意思的地方
还有一个挺有意思的组合就是TJ这个组合T呢就是理性就是thinking所以他们做事呢就比较严格根据成本收益就不太会做那种影响他们决策J呢就是比较有计划嘛
对吧
就是judging
这种人一般也都
比较自律比较严格
所以当T和J碰在一起呢
这种人一般就会
比较冷酷
自我要求比较严格
有些人可能会觉得
有些刻板啊
这种人就是TJ
这个呢也挺有意思的
就现在几大球王啊
比如说这个C罗
比如说小贝
梅西
这三个人都是TJ系
TJ系呢
也出了很多大企业家
比如刚才我们说的
Flag那几个创始人
也都是TJ系的
还有像Bill Gates
还有这个Warren Buffett
都是TJ系的
所以刚才说
Flag的这几个创始人呢
都是INTJ的
INTJ是不是比较适合当马
有可能
所以你看
这个就跟他那个工作
就比较相关了
虽然刚才我们说
这些性格完全
这16种人
人人平等啊
完全没有优劣之分
但是呢
不同的性格人
他可能适合从事的
不同的职业也不太一样
就是说他在不同职业当中
他可能会变成一个
会发挥他性格上的优势
变成一个更强的自己
针对不同性格的人的平均薪资
做过一个调查
基本上你看
这个ENTJ是这里边最高的
然后INFP是最低的
当然也没差那么多
就是INFP也千万不要那个悲伤
你们还是很有创造性的
所以你这么看
我还特意数了一下
一般就是EXXJ
就是外向和有计划型的
在职场上相对来讲
这个薪资会好一些
所以你看一般公司招人
都说我们希望你有
很好的communication skill
对吧
就是你可以去跟人交流
当然也不完全是这样
因为刚才我们说
这些int这些互联网公司
可能很多都是这种内向的人
然后这种有计划型的
也很好理解
对吧
一般在公司里头
肯定是希望大家都
能按规矩办事
如果你太屁
今天我今天不想来上班了
我不来了
明天这公司文件丢丢了吧
这就可能就不太好
如果你是屁
我觉得如果你想进这种
公司上班的话
还是最好养成一些
J的习惯
对于在职场比较有帮助
当然如果你觉得世界很大
你想去看看
哪天说走就走
就去旅行一下
可能也未必
不是一个好的人生啊
那回过头来说
人和人相处这块
性格会不会对人和人相处
造成一些影响呢
就什么样的人
和什么样的人适合在一起
适合结婚
适合做朋友
适合好的相处呢
其实这个没有说
一个特别明确的
一般来讲
外向的人和内向的人
他们其实还挺互补的
就不是说
非得外向的人
才能跟外向人聊得来
内向人聊得来
如果你是这种理性和感性
其实也是能相处得来的
包括你是计划还是灵活
好像你开始
如果你觉得两个
一对情侣
一个是计划型
一个是灵活型
可能不太能说到一块去
但其实很多情侣
都是计划和灵活这样搭配的
就可能计划型那个人
每天就做计划
灵活型那个人
就什么也不管
就跟着计划型那个人走
这样两个人也不容易打架
对吧
你说要是两个计划型的
计划没计划到一块去
万一又碰上两个
就是两个TJ和TJ在一块了
但是北一有一点区别的呢
就是这个具体型和直觉型
就是S型和N型
如果一个特别具体型
然后一个特别抽象型的人在一起
有可能会聊不到一块去
但也只是有可能
如果说你跟你女朋友
或者你跟你男朋友
是这两种类型
就没有任何意思啊
你们好好相处和平共处
所以回头说过来呢
我觉得做整个这个测试
对我影响最大的吧
就是我可以用这个测试
更了解我自己
比如说我自己是ENTJ
ENTJ呢
就是比较严格
比较上进
比较理性
缺点呢
就有的时候可能会太强势
或者会不太注意别人的感受
比如说什么事情
我都希望能有一个
比较好的达到目标
或者能做到最好
所以有的时候
有时候会忽略别人的感受
那我看完这个呢
我就知道
那我之后跟人交流的时候
都会注意一下这些东西
我就好奇
我把其他16个都看了一遍
然后我就试图着想
我身边有没有人
能套进这个性格里
真的是特别特别神奇
之前有的时候
我跟同事相处
一起做事
就总是有一些东西
拖到最后一个时间做
然后就来不及了
我就特别特别
就是焦虑啊
我就想他怎么就那么不努力
他为什么就不想
把这个事做好
但后来啊
做完这个东西
我终于意识到
原来他不过就是个屁啊
所以就释然了
因为其实人和人
完全就是不一样的
做完这个呢
我觉得一方面是我
可以更了解我自己
然后呢
也可以更了解身边的人
这样呢
当他们做出一些
我可能不太理解
事情的时候
我就觉得啊
其实就大家
可以互相理解一下
只是人性格和性格
不一样而已
没有任何的对错
那就可以让那个P
就是那个灵活型的人
去做一些比较有创造力的东西
然后让那个J
就是那个计划型的人
去做这个规划
总而言之的
就是我做完之后
我觉得这个真的还挺好玩的
就了解自己了解朋友
你可以猜一猜
根据这个刚才讲的这些逻辑
你猜猜你的朋友到底是什么
让他做一做
看看到底准不准
我在这个下面的信息栏里
也放了其他几个
这个测试的链接
大家有感兴趣的
也可以再做一做
有好几百道题
你可以尽情地去看看
你到底是什么性格
当然这个测试
我觉得它不一定是
我觉得
我怎么这么N
就是它不一定是百分之百准的
包括如果说你做出来
发现你在中间
你也可以两个都看一看
对吧
就说明你可能是两个中间的一个
好 今天聊了这么多
留到这儿的都是朋友
四海之内接朋友
所以留到这儿的呢
千万别忘了
关注点赞
我们下期见啦
拜拜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive